pas dit que les caméras les joueurs sont
arrivés ça je vais pouvoir les régler
rapidement
on a Wesley sceaux ici
et on va avoir Magnus Carlson qui va
être là
les caméras sont réglées
les joueurs sont là
ça devrait commencer il y a eu un petit
j'ai pas envie de dire retard à
l'allumage parce que c'est pas le cas
mais c'est moi j'ai pas j'ai pas eu
accès directement au temps en avance que
d'habitude
au calme et le match a commencé en
réalité mais attendez je suis déconnecté
de la page
de toute façon raté voilà peut-être les
30 premières secondes
j'arrive pas à ouvrir la partie
la partie ne s'ouvre pas c'est pas
forcément la bonne nouvelle
la partie ne s'ouvre pas
alors attendez une petite seconde je
vais tenter un truc
je reviens dans une seconde c'est un
petit bug ça devrait ça devrait aller
ça devrait ça devrait venir je vous mets
le tableau je pense savoir comment le
régler
c'est dommage de rater le tout début du
match mais
c'est indépendant de ma volonté
on va essayer de la voir maintenant
ok on va la voir une petite seconde les
amis
et voilà
on va revenir sur les coups qu'on a raté
donc c'est une espagnole
ah il rejoue ce truc avec des trois des
quatre il l'avait joué contre kaimer
Magnus
à la Coupe du monde et il avait eu cette
position déjà je vous avais fait une
vidéo dessus d'ailleurs c'est la gaffe
incroyable de Carlson ou un truc comme
ça ou la spéciale de Carson
peu importe
et donc se positionne un peu analysé sur
un jeu correct des Noirs ça va être
complètement égal
j'ai l'impression que Magnus c'est ce
que je voyais quand je regarde un peu
l'avantage l'avant match à du coup en
anglais il semble un peu malade un peu
fatigué ouais je crois qu'il a il a
turbo flemme
mais bon ça
[Musique]
il devrait se motiver au fil du match
ceux qui se lève en pleine partie
allons-y pourquoi pas
et pourquoi pas
se déplacer pendant les game
donc il revient
il est parti il est revenu je vérifie
que tout soit bien
il a ok je vérifie
donc il a mis la tour en vin
protège le pion on va voir comment ça
évolue partie un peu un peu molle
fous des cartes il va contrôler la case
F6
c'est 3 il va remettre le four en G7
B3 il va faire tout aussi
tour 8 partie est pas très emballé
entre les voir en cas mais c'est pour le
montage maintenant ça va là les cames
elles passent non c'est bon c'est bon
ils m'ont fait peur
bon après ça joue cavalier contre fou
mais c'est assez égal moi je prendrai
les blancs personnellement j'aurais
l'impression que les Noirs ont du mal à
créer un pion passé ouais je pense que
les blancs sont un peu mieux
bien jouer de la part de Magnus quand
même
bien joué parce qu'il y a des pions
doublés la structure est pas si simple à
faire progresser il veut échanger les
tours et pressé dans la finale cavalier
contre foussé hyper bien joué de la part
de Magnus là pour le coup
ouais non c'est hyper bien je vais de la
part de Magnus là franchement
c'est on voit tous les pions sur case
noir si réussi à bloquer
c'est réussi à tout bloquer sur case
noire et après à valoriser sa majorité à
l'elroit il pourra vraiment prétendre à
gagner après ça c'est tellement un bon
défenseur qui va falloir être très
propre peut-être un coup comme cavalier
de ici intéressant il peut même passer
après la tour en A4
il commence par tourger 4 ça j'ai envie
de dire
c'est un coin intermédiaire intéressant
je pense qu'elle va lier E2 avec ID sur
faux 5 tours A4 partir là-bas se mettre
en face du pion
et essayer après d'avoir les mains
libres pour pousser de ce côté
je pense qu'il va tenter un truc comme
ça mais après c'est Magnus il est
nettement plus fort que moi moi je vous
dis l'idée que je regarderai en
principalement mais évidemment
il a dix fois ou 20 fois ou 30 fois ou
50 fois ou 100 fois mon niveau donc
ben on va on va on va
admirer l'artiste et il fait ça ouais je
suis quand je suis content je m'envoie
des fleurs on vient faut bien se faire
un peu kiffer aussi de mon côté les
matchs sont sont longs alors que je vois
que les scores
sont pas bien à jour ici
c'est pas le quart de finale mais c'est
une demi finale
mais ouais on se délecte évidemment
ah non ils sont tellement forts que moi
mais bon du coup j'essaye un peu deviné
de vous dire ce que je vois après ce
sera jamais au niveau de ses joueurs
c'est impossible
mais ouais c'est juste que c'est assez
logique
après je dois dire que pour progresser
en finale j'ai regardé énormément de
parties de Magnus
pour essayer de
[Musique]
d'avoir les réflexes et les coûts qui
joueraient mais après évidemment je les
ai pas tout le temps genre là de
remettre la tour en H4 faire 3g2 et se
prendre l'idée d'avoir cavalier F4 tour
H5 parfois peut-être et de contrôler un
peu de faire l'essuie-glace c'est fort
et là il veut jouer tourage 5 maintenant
et cavalier F4 qui est D3 et tapé le
pion S c'est hyper fort
ouais bon c'est c'est une autre galaxie
je sais pas comment il va y arriver
concrètement mais c'est une autre
galaxie
on leur dit que c'est faute mais bon
c'est une autre galaxie
c'est la galaxie Magnus c'est magnifique
en fait ce qu'il fait sur A4 il veut car
il est D3 et ABAB tour à deux il y a
Tours français 5 et s'il fait tout à 5
pour défendre il y aura B4 qui jouera
sur le clouage
donc le seul coup pour défendre c'est
ABAB C4 donner le pion et mettre la tour
en deux
ce qui va trouver ça qui est
extraordinaire
donc là il a trouvé la défense parce que
c'était les seuls coups
c'est comme ça qui s'est retrouvé à
avoir la défense
donc cavalier B4 il y a quand même un
avantage au temps pour Magnus
c'est tellement fort qui a ici il y a
pas droit 8 il y a
tour des 8 mats et sur wifi ça te
reprend des 4 protège le pion C4
il va faire tourger 4 tu penses
pour toucher le fou et son seul problème
c'est le cavalier qui peut se retrouver
bizarre après fouf 6
ça qui fait tout rêve 4 pour cavalier
des 8 mais qu'est-ce qu'il est fort mon
Dieu oh là là c'est horrible enfin
horrible horrible horrible de jouer
contre lui
ah c'est terrible
c'est une première démonstration déjà à
la de Magnus qui a simplement été
monstrueux
donc ouais c'est qui tente d'envoyer le
B3 fou B2
ah la partie qui vient de lui sortir
c'est un
c'est une master class
qui s'appelle conscience qui s'appelle
joue un genre de système de Londres à
couleur inversée si vous regardez bien
en fait en tout cas dans le comme on en
parlait avant dans le dans le placement
de pièces ça ressemble à ça
et on va le pion à 5
il échange les pièces
quel début de la part de Magnus quand
même énorme au début de match on le
sentait
plutôt sur le reculoir vu l'attitude
entre guillemets
on le sent plutôt
plutôt fatigué pour une raison X ou Y
mais bon il est tellement fort aux
échecs
apparemment un petit peu malade en tout
cas
c'est ce que j'ai pu lire
mais quoi qu'il en soit seraosphérique
quoi qu'il en soit stratosphérique
donc là il a placé le pion en C6 et il
contrôle le centre la position est très
plate en fait je comprends tout à fait
ce que fait Magnus c'est
très logique
en gros il fait rien
il laisse Wesley prendre la
responsabilité du jeu et Magnus si c'est
une finale il est très content parce
qu'il est plus fort
donc en fait il joue un peu au jeu du
chat et de la souris
et c'est très malin en terme de
stratégie c'est à dire qui prend un peu
Wesley à son propre piège en quelque
sorte c'est quoi
qui aime bien jouer des positions on va
dire sécuritaire
et Magnus les lui donne en lui disant
bah écoute c'est pas un souci de toute
façon je suis plus fort que toi
en finale
donc en soi il veut lui dire si le match
se déroule de cette manière et que
on avance peu à peu pas dans des
positions on va dire technique ben ouais
il aura toujours le dernier mot ouais
c'est Magnus aura toujours le dernier
mot
je trouve que c'est une manière
d'aborder le match en tout cas sur ce
qu'on ressent sur ces deux premières
parties très intelligentes de la part de
Magnus oui il tape entre guillemets sur
les sur les faiblesses de l'adversaire
tout en utilisant ces points forts
mais là l'ordinateur annonce avantage
blanc mais moi je pense que les noirs
sont mieux j'aurais l'impression que je
vais installer une tour en C8 en C3
pardon et que ça va aller donc il va
jouer ton français 5 et il va mettre la
tour en C8 la tour en C3 moi j'aurais
plutôt préféré les Noirs ici
intuitivement kb8 qui est ici pour
dégager le cavalier c'est très bien joué
donc oui et non la
Manu ça a vraiment pris le
le match du bon côté
et donc demain à 18h l'autre demi-finale
entre mvl
et Carole à caméra qui sera pour nous le
point d'orgue du tournoi
évidemment c'est le match de Maxime un
autre joueur français qui nous intéresse
le plus
et c'est bien normal là il va essayer de
jouer avec fuf 5 pour s'enlever du bas
du couloir où j'ai 5 et tour à 5 tours
C3 tours C5 c'est le plan des Noirs mais
probablement on peut tout défendre avec
les Blancs et ça va juste probablement
mener à la nul cependant c'est quand
même les noirs qui essayent de prendre
l'initiative du jeu si le match
continue comme il vient de le commencer
ça peut être dur pour Wesley quoique
qui est intéressant
objectivement Naka est favori alors oui
oui Nakamura il gagne il gagne tous les
ans le speechess
il est forcément favori de n'importe
quel match
ikawa actuellement maintenant
maxime a montré de belles choses
les semaines passées
mais
il a de nombreuses victoires
consécutives en speechasse
donc pour moi il est forcément favori
et pas Manu ça parle en dernier ouais
Manu c'était la l'an dernier et il Caro
lui avait marché dessus donc
pour moi celui qui est tenant du titre
qui a gagné l'année précédente etc et
forcément favoris
ouais en ligne il faudra vraiment tout
le monde donc là de manière un peu
étonnante les blancs vont se retourner
bien
la partie semblait prendre un autre
scénario d'ailleurs on voit Magnus un
qui attend qui est pas mal de temps
mais ouais demain 18h ce sera
les normes affiches
des quatre avantages ici
je pense pas ça fera revivre le fouet 5
au contraire un coup comme des quatre
qui met la tour en B5
ça doit se tenir avec
avec les Noirs mais ça peut devenir
dangereux
imagine qu'ils reprennent de la tour
quand même reprendre avec ah c'est un
peu à double tranchant quoi que ça peut
se risquer
bon là il joue pour tout fermer sur
blanc là c'est vraiment magnifique il
joue le la forteresse
entre guillemets
entre guillemets il joue il joue la
forteresse il essaie de tout bloquer
regardez là le fou il va il va plus
vivre il va y avoir des tours des 5 qui
vont arriver ça va égaliser intéressant
parce qu'on s'attendait pas trop à ça
comme je disais il semblait que c'était
plutôt le rayon de de Magnus tout ça
qui sert vraiment plus à rien
position vraiment difficile
je leur dis qu'il réaffiche
OK
il se trouve du contre-jour via H4
il y a pas fou point 4 à cause de toi
quelle défense de Magnus
ah ouais c'est costaud très franchement
c'est très costaud parce que maintenant
il y a tout trois tours G2
donc il va faire roi géant et tour à
deux maintenant tu reprends à 3 et tu
reprends G3 qu'est-ce qui vient de faire
ma nièce
ah exceptionnel
exceptionnel enchaînement de Magnus
alors qu'il était vraiment mal hein
alors elle est pas encore gagnée
il va faire
ça marche peut-être pas
c'est le coup qu'on a envie de jouer
alors dis et pas fan mais ouais c'était
trop normal il va faire en C4 là
c'est trop normal
mais ça va gagner quand même non il va
mettre l'option G3 là
c'est trop normal de bloquer le roi il y
a pas de roi G2 il menace tour C1
il va faire corser deux ah c'est bien
joué à foue 4 il va peut-être se la
tenir Wesley
au prix d'une giga défense attention
quand il y a le roi qui va monter
il y a le pion E5 qui crie famine
il défend très très bien il est
il va faire 8 fois 5 je pense
avec ID tour des 5 tours 5
oh
encore bien joué c'est pour ça qu'il
revient avec le roi pour défendre il
veut chasser le fou il revient avec la
tour en des deux fouger 6 c'est encore
bien joué
et maintenant il veut monter le roi vers
mais qu'est-ce qu'ils sont forts les
deux
je peux vous dire que ça joue
extrêmement fort côté Wesley sur la
Renaissance
mais bon il va essayer de monter Magnus
il va mettre le fond H3 je pense
ok il monte le pion en fait il veut se
retrouver avec un tour fou contre tour
waouh la défense de Wesley for F4 au
meilleur des moments pour tout échanger
exceptionnel
c'était vraiment fort c'était très très
fort des deux côtés
très très belle passe d'armes
il est pas passé loin et puis en plus
dans un match comme ça faire le break ça
aurait été très positif
forcément à découvrir
et le mettre sous pression
évidemment si tu si tu prends un lead à
ce niveau là s'ils prennent 4 5 points
de Lead normalement surtout si c'est
Magnus ça revient pas derrière
normalement après on sait jamais donc là
il avait une balle de 2-0 c'est quand
même un premier break dans le match
possible
donc on est on est à quoi on est à 25
minutes de match
ça a l'air plutôt cool au blanc
avec le plan d'aller attaquer mais après
ça c'est moi qui mes petits biais
cognitifs
mais l'autre demi à l'opposera mvl à
ikarona caméra demain à 18h donc c'est
vraiment
ce qui demande dans le chat
je sais pas comment il peut gagner bah
juste parce que c'est le got en fait
c'est juste que c'est le meilleur joueur
de l'histoire des échecs qui peut battre
n'importe qui
je pense tu vas faire un roi B1 au
moment donné parce qu'il y a trop de
lignes il y a fougères 5 qui est utile
ouais c'est
pas simple à jouer avec les Noirs je
trouve
et j'ai quatre
je sais pas ce qui se passe surprise D5
va me prendre des seins qui veut jouer
la finale en live faire ouais je pense
qu'il veut dame prend des cinq prises
dessin et F4 bon ceux qui veut tout
liquider c'est bien joué quand même
ça va changer il va faire F4 je pense il
veut que le retour 5
à moins qu'il joue dans
je pense ça va faire F4 là couper tout
E5 mettre une tour en 1 mais la finale
elle est nulle
5 et contrôler toutes les cases de la
colonneuse c'est bien joué
c'est très bien joué de la part de
Magnus très très bien joué très bien
pensé mais après
c'est une elle peut pas être mieux que
nul pour aucun des deux joueurs après
ça va jouer
ça va jouer ici et on a vu dans la
partie précédente il peut encore y avoir
des surprises il fait F4 maintenant on a
compris son idée de toute façon F4
c'est un coup vers l'avant qu'on avait
envie de jouer tôt ou tard
mais il a laissé un peu
rester dans les spectateurs
donc ouais c'est bien joué
vraiment bien joué
et là regardez ce qui se passe pendant
la tour des cinq elle est enfermée c'est
incroyable saut qui s'est fait prendre
comme un débutant
il s'est fait enfermer la tour en fait
il devait vraiment revenir vers E5 et là
il devait faire tourner 5
et c'est juste fait enfermer la tour
ouais c'est incroyable ça
c'est incroyable comme un bleu
alors la surfer c'est quoi l'idée
c'est fou prends un 4 tu reprends le 3
puis on prend le 3 il faut prendre des 5
E2 ok mais Magnus le voit il a fait G5
intermédiaires
et fous bouge c'est fou et quatre non tu
reprends le 4 temps
c'est très très bien défendu quand même
de la part de Wesley
ouais
et la foule 4
il ramasse la cale
et il va essayer d'aller bouffer à 6 et
gagner la finale
c'est beaucoup trop fort je sais de
calculer des variantes de mon côté aussi
mais
c'est beaucoup trop fort à côté Magnus
et ouais heureusement quoi il a pas
perdu la précédente ça aurait fait trois
points déjà
ouais et ça abandon de rester il aurait
pu la jouer un peu plus longtemps mais
bon et que
ça fait mal le début tonitruant de
Magnus Carlsen
on va dire et même pas forcément bien
payer au vu de son niveau de jeu là sur
sur ce début de match
un match qui peut devenir long pour
Wesley si Magnus continue à appuyer sur
le champignon comme ça avec un air
totalement désinvolte
après c'est lui le got des échecs
il est absolument injouable Magnus et il
est en train de le prouver une nouvelle
fois
dans une attitude très désinvolte mais
ma foi à chacun l'attitude qu'il
souhaite il y a pas de pas
d'interdiction
on a le droit d'être désinvolte
c'est autorisé
vous savez qu'il a qu'à vous dites qu'il
a 42 fièvre bah c'est 40 de fièvre je
pense pas qu'ils puissent être
assis comme ça
non non je pense pas c'est même pas sûr
qu'il soit vraiment malade dans ces gens
qui ont dit ça parce qu'il a l'air
malade mais
il est peut-être juste en mode racaille
c'est peut-être un mood
pas vrai quand tu es tellement le got
c'est facile
son côté obscur ouais c'est son côté
je suis fatigué à force de vous Ken
c'est
trop facile pour lui
Barça sous quel est
en mode manga
après il est tard pour pour Magnus aussi
les il est comme pour nous un 22h je
crois que c'est la même horaire
peut-être qu'il faut un peu se réveiller
j'ai quoi trop ouais c'est bien joué de
la part de OS c'est il essaye de jouer
sur le cavalier F6 qui a plus trop de
cases
pour se donner une case au roi H8
en tout cas
Wesley qui a changé de stratégie il a
arrêté les finales
il essaie de gêner d'entrer
ni il essaie d'agresser d'entrer
du coup parce qu'il doit il doit se
donner la case de repli pour le cheval
bien joué
ouais c'est bien joué il replace ses
pièces et
au final Wesley ouais qui se place aussi
mais il va se prendre tous ces 7 dessins
maintenant il donne les cases et sinon
c'est des seins qui arrivent
moi j'aimerais bien avoir un Magnus
prendre ses aises
et faire et faire un premier écart là un
gros break plus 3 et peut-être même
tourner à plus 4 rêves
avant le Water break
rayon du maximum
il fait 4 mais bon maintenant après
c'est dégueu
défi c'est et on va pouvoir sortir les
pièces côté Magnus les pièces blanches
sont pas forcément bien placées des 6 il
va peut-être tenter cavaler au 3 allez
c'est pour ça qu'il calme cette fois
cinq échecs d'ailleurs en premier pour
forcer une décision
c'est une leçon d'échec
c'est très très fort franchement
très autoritaire Magnus dans ces parties
il va mettre le cas et c'est
ouais le niveau de jeu est
assez incroyable
et la domination magnussienne sur son
adversaire et son emprise
est extraordinaire et maintenant il fait
F5 il ouvre tout
ouais c'est fou prends F4 puis on prend
le la tour de retour en géant puis on
prend le 4 fois regarder la ligne c'est
horrible
non mais regardez-moi ça découper
le joueur américain
obligé de faire du roi G1
impressionnant Magnus
va alors c'est pas fini il faut se
défendre quand même bien trouve les
meilleurs coups
je pense qu'il va coller un fou c'est
trois fous des quatre maintenant
c'est terrible il va échanger et c'est
lui qui aura le pion passé
mais au supplice West les sauts
de la tête et des épaules
c'est très très propre ce que ce que
réalise
le champion du monde de Blitz
il va y avoir du dames 8 damage 5 je
pense il va décaler
plus de 15
il va devoir faire il y aura une
double attaque
ça va faire trois oh le match va être
long mesdames et messieurs pour rester
si ça continue comme ça
c'est une leçon d'échec
tout simplement qui est en train de
prendre Wesley SOS
ouais il a plus de temps il arrive même
pas à jouer il se fait
exploser
il est complètement fixé c'est une
horreur
c'est une horreur gluante
enfin il abandonne carrément
ah c'est trop tellement la position
était dégueu il a juste décidé
d'abandonner
et ça fait trois pour Magnus bon et là
celle-là avant la pose elle est
importante parce que si Magnus réussir à
prendre au blanc ça va faire 4
et j'ai envie de vous dire
ça va être du Chao bon après Magnus pour
moi était énorme favori je l'aurais mis
gagnant
évidemment mais je m'attendais à un
début de match en tout cas nettement
plus serré
vice qui se font c'est grave ouais après
c'est
enfin je sais pas comment dire quoi
il tombe sur du Grand Magnus il a pas le
style pour le battre quoi
ouais c'est c'est du Magnus c'est du
Magnus pur jus
après
Wesley j'avais pas trouvé d'un contrat
lyreza allez résa avait à mieux jouer
mais il a mal géré son match mais ici
qui a de m'en parlera était plus fort
que
que Wesley en tout cas de mon point de
vue
some avait paru assez emprunté
donc
s'il est sur la lignée de son niveau de
jeu contre contre Ali resa en fait
l'écart avec Magnus c'est incroyable
quel genre pour
ce qu'on voit là il y en a à deux
mais il s'appelle mvl et Hikaru genre
réellement c'est les deux autres
demi-finalistes Maxime
c'est un mauvais matchup pour Magnus
même si Magnus serait favori mais c'est
un joueur qui gêne Magnus Maxime quand
il est en grande forme et Hikaru c'est
quand même le favori du tournoi
j'ai pas trop la ref il avait quand même
battu il y a deux ou trois ans en
speechess il a battu en championnat du
monde de Blitz
je vois pas pourquoi ça s'amuse
elle a déjà battu dans ce format ouais
c'est un des rares donc
ouais le problème c'est carreaux elle a
beaucoup plus de problèmes contre Caro
c'est un mauvais match up
le seul avec le h à barbe je crois ouais
bon là ça a l'air OK pour les Noirs mais
ça joue souvent au tempo ces trucs là
[Musique]
là c'est pas vraiment une question
d'ouverture c'est que
en fait Maxime il aime bien
mettre ses adversaires sous une tempête
tactique et il peut le faire contre tous
les joueurs dans le monde sauf icaru et
du coup en fait
la difficulté que Maxime a compris
carrous c'est qu'en point fort contre
points forts où il est plus fort
donc Maxime peut plus se reposer sur son
arme principale avec laquelle il a
l'habitude de battre les joueurs
et
ouais c'est comme un duel au tennis
entre deux gros serveurs
mais ils ont toujours l'habitude de
gagner leur Satan break
genre mais il y en a un qui sert mieux
que l'autre
alors que sur des matchs différents ils
auraient d'autres qualités
je pense sur qu'il y avait prendre des 5
il faut prendre des 5 dames prends des 5
dames prends des cinq cavalier 7 38 qui
est prend des 5 et jouer sur l'enfilade
Magnus
donc en fait Maxime il se retrouve un
peu dépourvu de son arme principale et
il arrive pas à déborder Hikaru dans
d'autres secteurs de jeux
alors que d'un point de vue asymétrique
c'est pas clair quoi
mon imbécile c'est pour éviter tous ces
problèmes et attaquer le Pione F2 hein
désolé je regardais la deuxième caméra
comme vous demander comment on sait
qu'ils ont pas qui regardent pas sur un
deuxième écran mais tout simplement
parce qu'on le voit
les défaites de mvl face à école souvent
c'est Hikaru qui ressort plus souvent
gagnant que Maxime
je me rappelle même avoir commenté des
parties longues de ML contre Caro
mais ouais dans le petit jeu tactique ou
Maxime règne en mètre généralement un
contre-caru
c'est le seul joueur qui réussit à la
la position reste intéressante
son pire apparemment d'après son profil
Chase base ça m'étonne pas c'est
vraiment un joueur qui veut réussir pas
allez c'est vrai que à l'IRESA peut
gêner Hikaru
alors que pour Maxime c'est plutôt un
bon match à l'IRESA
je sais pas c'est un peu bizarre les
styles des machins et tout les niveaux
sont tellement serrés
et Caro historiquement le joueur qui
veut réussir pas du tout c'est Magnus
même si les choses semblent avoir un
petit peu changé
en tout cas en réel c'est Magnus
et Magnus sont pires matchup en termes
on va dire de niveau et de style c'est
Maxime
et dingleren aussi lui poser des
problèmes quand il était fort
quand il était à son meilleur niveau
et Caro est beaucoup moins fort en réel
qu'en ligne il est quand même moins fort
en réel ouais
mais à l'époque ouais mais le truc c'est
que Carolina et Magnus ils avaient
quasiment le même niveau je parlais de
matchup en termes
ouais Maxime il a quand même beaucoup
gêné Magnus
là il s'est un peu emmêlé les pinceaux
il était fait un temps Manu c'était
nettoyé
ça suit là le pion des 6 c'est dur à
défendre
on va voir c'est peut-être une partie
qui tourne bien pour
pour rester là pas forcément très mérité
mais il a quand même bien défendu
allez il faut il faut la gagner pour
remettre un peu de suspense trois points
d'écart faudrait revenir à deux points
avant le avant le break
on va essayer qui est en train de perdre
de précieuses secondes là
4 ça va cavalier prank et des 5 qui veut
c'est sûr
vous prend ces quatre
plus de 17 secondes pour Wesley
ouais
il bondit là Magnus talent Nico
et ça ça s'appelle une pièce raté
cavalier 8
ouais celle-là elle fait extrêmement mal
à Wesley qui avait une super balle de
contre et qu'il a pas ça passe à moins 4
il est parti furax de sa chaise mais
ouais 4 4 points d'écart c'est pas match
plié mais bon ça sent très mauvais les
amis je vais essayer de me manger un
tout petit truc pour un peu récup de
force que ça va finir très tard et on se
retrouve après la pause à tout de suite
les amis
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surplus a du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechess ou
les title Tuesday
chess.com/aventem tous les plus grands
tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez comprenez
en direct les parties des meilleurs
joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
les amis je vous ai chopé une info
intéressante pendant la pause
et je peux une info
sur sur
avoir une chance dans ce match
il aurait besoin en quelque sorte
d'avoir de l'avance avant le avant le
1+1 parce que le Bullet était un réel
problème
bon là il est déjà mené 4-0 en 5 + 1 je
pense que dans son esprit il a quasiment
déjà perdu le match
je vous le dis tout de suite je pense
que dans son esprit le match est déjà
proche de terminer bon il reste encore
trois heures de compétition pour être
bien sûr
mais ouais bon il est obligé de
continuer à jouer mais je pense que pour
lui
c'est déjà fini alors est-ce que les
parties ont repris normalement non mais
j'ai quand même c'est vrai non
apparemment non
mais ouais il a il est déjà quatre
points en retard
si considérait qu'il devait prendre de
l'avance avant le Bullet ça paraît
très compliqué il reste 37 minutes allez
peut-être essayer de revenir
ça semble compliqué
car scène qui domine ça ouais donc c'est
une ressource
c'est vraiment un peu rampante
plus d'avance à 6 points le match sera
vraiment plié
un peu dommage dans ce speechesse après
on a eu on a eu quoi comme beau match on
a eu soit dit raisin qui est un peu
décousu mais qui était sympa
mon appât vraiment trouvé de match
sympathique
édition un peu un peu triste pour le
moment
les gros joueurs en fait vraiment
favoris du tournoi
non pas non pas subi le moindre danger
la plupart des matchs étaient pliés en
40 minutes là comme aujourd'hui en fait
visuellement
la finale devrait pas décevoir écoutons
on espère déjà on espère un gros match
demain soir et nous la finale on la
suivra ensemble elle spot
vous pouvez venir on sera on fera on va
tenter un vieux pinview parti pas besoin
de place vous pouvez juste vous pointer
au début
ouais ouais ça il y a eu du suspense
pendant une heure et demie deux heures
après ça a déroulé
une heure et demie peut-être
qu'elle prend le 5 marche pas il y a
Damas 5 évidemment
c'est le pire phase même pas un piège
donc ouais ça ce sera vendredi à 19h
venez un petit peu avant si vous voulez
voir la vie ou partie peut-être vers
18h30 18h
on se mettra bien
suivre ça à la cool
menace peut-être il prend le 5
maintenant
illustrer tranquille
faut qu'il continue à faire le taf et
mener son match petit à petit jusqu'à la
victoire
plus facile à dire qu'à faire évidemment
il faut rester concentré pas perdre de
l'intérêt pour le match
et si on voulait éviter ça qu'est-ce
qu'il faudrait changer au speechess
comme format ah il faudrait il faudrait
jouer en format 7
ce qui permettrait là que Magnus
maintenant 7-0 et qu'on reparte entre
guillemets sur un deuxième set un peu
comme au tennis en réalité on se heurte
un petit peu au problème qu'a eu le
tennis quand il a voulu introduire là il
y a deux trois ans le système de temps
ou finalement ça marche pas du tout mais
on a un peu le même problème avec les
échecs pour les raisons
très similaires
Magnus a jamais de choc pour avoir une
interférer frérot j'essaye de garder de
l'intérêt dans le match aide-moi
aide-moi
j'essaye de te garder de l'intérêt dans
le match parce que là visuellement
c'est kata
visuellement c'est kata
voilà jauge qui préfère les blancs mais
oui la position elle me semble pas du
tout mieux blanc c'est ils vont un pion
de plus mais la poupée 5 peut-être
arrive
il a pas l'air content Wesley même si sa
position va
après la Magnus il joue de manière un
peu un peu risqué
pas forcément la meilleure manière de
prendre Wesley
mais bon il y a un gros avantage au
score
est-ce que au niveau on le voit pas
vraiment en tournant un dernièrement
tu sais que le monde des échecs est
cruel quand tu te rends compte que
carpave n'a jamais emporté un match
contre carpe paroles mais il les a pas
tous perdus important
il en a jamais remporté un mais il ne
les a pas tous perdu
malgré que tous les matchs
auraient dû connaître un vainqueur
voilà c'est un pion de plus quand même
pour les blancs il y a pas assez
d'activités
mais il y aura peut-être assez de jeux
pour réussir à tenir la nul on va voir
mais c'est simplement un pion de plus
c'est les blancs vont tenter de les
mettre en mouvement
les conventions ben quoi avec une
structure
qui ne l'est pas du tout
comme tu seras dispo tu commenceras pas
la finale sur switch si on va la
commenter sur twitch et Alice pot en
même temps
ça qui est beau mais pas sur la chaîne
de James com
on va se faire un truc un peu parce
qu'on sait pas si ça va bien marcher il
y a trop de
d'interrogations
ouais bon là c'est clairement avantage
blanc l'option de plus il est quand même
relativement clean après pas facile à
avancer
on va voir si Wesley réussit à mettre la
marche avant
ou s'il n'y arrive pas
je me demande ce que boit Magnus en fait
il a bien raison
c'est bien joué là d'avoir d'utiliser
les pions pour se prendre des cases
bah si ouais c'est gagne pas cette
partie
là il fait vraiment une bonne partie
pour le moment il fait vraiment une
bonne partie Wesley
Manu qui lui a permis de
d'imposer son style en quelque sorte
prendre son pion de plus jouer pleutre
il sait faire Wesley
res pour réussir à replacer la tour en
il est obligé de faire tourner F5 non
j'ai 4G3 et il faudrait pouvoir faire H4
en un coup pour que ce soit maths
il va y avoir E4 échec
on va prendre 4 ou 2
c'est ça le coup
ouais c'est trouvé qu'est-ce que c'est
bien joué de la part de Magnus c'est
ordinateur c'est pour ça que j'avais
mais c'est pas sûr qu'il est tous les
coups que sur tous les deux alors dit il
fait froid
et t'en prends deux fou prends un
et sur foot français 1 il y a tour D8
échecs
c'est pas si clair hein ce qui menace ou
4 encore
et peut-être un truc de type fougères 6
et quelque chose
plus que 26 secondes pour Wesley il est
obligé de la gagner celle-là
il va faire F5 échec je pense Magnus il
fait fougère
et bien joué de la part de Wesley
le roi qui se balade
et ça m'agus il va pas pouvoir
l'arnaquer
salam a eu s'il peut pas l'arnaquer
malgré toutes ces tentatives
mais bon on sent que il est plus à
l'aise en belette que Wesley
on sent que dans les grosses notes comme
ça
[Musique]
ça peut mal tourner pour Wesley
ça se voit là il s'embrouille tout seul
ok il réussit à
gagner la game péniblement
allez mettre un peu de baume au coeur
il revient à trois points
et il garde
une toute petite dose de suspense mais
on sent qu'on peut être ça va être dur
donc
je vois vraiment pas en vrai comment il
revient mais bon
on peut espérer qu'il revienne comme ça
graduellement et qui crée l'explor en
belette
mais non bien joué de la part de
Magnus part au bout de sa vie ouais les
joueurs ont pas l'air de
kiffer c'est quelque chose ça on m'a
beaucoup fait le retour sur ces matchs
de speechestre que les joueurs avaient
pas l'air respiré pas le bonheur en fait
pendant les matchs je sais pas ce que
vous en avez pensé
une version avec nous ouais bon après
c'est pas là qui vont mettre leurs
meilleurs nouveautés
et oui ils peuvent voir la caméra de
adversaire ouais
mais je crois que les joueurs ont plutôt
kiffé le championnat du monde de belette
par exemple
je crois que c'est un truc qui avait pas
mal fait kiffer les joueurs en tout cas
c'est le sentiment que j'avais
mais je pense juste que comme les matchs
sont très longs en fait c'est pas c'est
ça qui rend le truc pas très kiffant
c'est que tu sais que ça va durer 4
heures et le
le truc est étalé quoi le Bullet ça
durait 45 minutes tu viens tu cliques
c'est cool
4h c'est vrai que c'est long tu as pas
envie en fait personne n'a envie
merci c'est pas un truc léger quoi
mais je pense qu'il est capable de jouer
correctement la nuit ça a pas l'air
d'être un couche tôt Carlson
en tout cas la petite finale encore une
fois meilleur structure
très difficile à jouer contre Magnus
dans ses positions
il continue ça marche en avant
minus à mettre au supplice l'adversaire
il va pas toutes les gagner c'est final
parce qu'elles sont proches des gars
mais le truc c'est qu'il épuise son
adversaire et en plus il en gagne pas
mal
donc les deux combinés c'est vraiment
une opération intéressante pour minus
on va c'est qui qui touche à quelque
chose c'est la lumière qui le gène
pas l'air d'avoir le setup le plus le
plus confortable ouais c'est
tu me voyais regarder si c'est plutôt
c'est ça que j'étais en train d'observer
parce que sur les finales je crois que
il a un tel placement de pièces
naturelles que pas énormément
et c'était contre Maxime mais c'était
l'an dernier Maxime je vais pas très
bien l'an dernier
et ça lui avait permis de passer entre
guillemets
il est abonné à setup pourri ouais ouais
après il est mieux sur le setup chez lui
j'ai l'impression que le
le côté des joueurs qui ont l'air un peu
blasé en fait
tu sens pas qu'ils prennent qu'ils
prennent du plaisir en réalité pendant
pendant ces matchs
il va la tenir normalement ça finale
j'ai une bonne série là
une petite base de régime ce qui est
normal après avoir fait les cars après
les finales les gagnera pas tout un
ouais ouais c'était fait engueuler par
la gardienne exactement c'était le match
de l'an dernier contre
contre Maxime il avait été victime d'une
tempête de neige Wesley pour la petite
histoire
c'était dire une tempête de neige il
avait plus il avait plus Internet
partout et il avait trouvé comme option
d'aller il va y avoir ces quatre d'aller
dans la bibliothèque à côté de chez lui
à côté on sait pas mais en tout cas dans
sa ville
en tout cas dans sa vie
il y a une prise d'espace des blancs
mais les pions devraient être bloqué
c'était la petite anecdote du speechers
de l'an dernier je pense que sans ça
Wesley aurait battu Maxime des Maxime
était en bien moins bonne forme l'an
dernier alors que Magnus est en train de
nouveau de réussir à mettre une petite
pression ce qui paraît assez incroyable
il laisse du temps français 4 mais il
veut bouffer les pions de l'autre côté
et essayer de jouer contre le fait que
si on perçait en fait et qu'on reste
avec cette triplette de pions ça change
pas grand chose d'en avoir qu'un en fait
entre deux
en tour des 8 tours des deux ça ça va
être joué assez vite et il peut jouer
avec ton D6 aussi au F7 ouais c'est
pas une partie qui doit
nous mener bien loin
mais là il devrait y avoir un point de
blocage pour les blancs
on doit pas pouvoir progresser ici
la progression doit être bloqué là
il va remettre une tourelle et en fait
la tour des reins est liée au pion
et on va être obligé de répéter les
coups côté Magnus
vous voyez Magnus comme d'hab il veut
pas faire nul c'est incroyable
il veut qui est hors des 4 tours H7
tours 7 et essayer
avec ce setup de faire quelque chose
mais du couple aura et c'est
waouh c'est relou à jouer en face de
Magnus
il va y faire deux rois de ces deux
j'imagine
il peut pas aller prendre F6 là c'est
trop
ah non il peut pas
il voudrait mais il peut pas aller ça
fait nul
pourquoi il joue parce que Magnus c'est
un joueur qui est assez entêté si
tant qui peut tenter de jouer le gain il
tente
Magnus c'est pas quelqu'un qui qui donne
des demi points comme ça
et il a bien raison
on n'a jamais gagné une partie en
acceptant une nul
et comme il fait très très peu d'erreurs
Magnus il essaye toujours de pousser
les parties le plus longtemps possible
et il a entièrement raison
c'est ça marque de fabrique c'est
quelque chose de nouveau qui l'a apporté
aux échecs
on poussait moins les parties avant
l'émergence de Minus
on va pas lui en vouloir pour ça
on ne va pas lui en vouloir pour ça
des choses qu'on voit pas mais
c'est juste que
il fait moins d'erreurs que les autres
et il est vrai dans il est juste plus
fort en fait
c'est ça
il est plus fort il est plus fort
qu'est-ce que vous voulez mais donc
c'est pour ça qu'il a raison de jouer le
plus longtemps possible parce que plus
il joue
plus son adversaire peut faire une faute
quoi
te rappelle la première fois que tu as
entendu parler de Magnus ouais première
fois que j'entends une parler de Magnus
c'est quand je l'ai vu je l'ai vu en
tournant que jour en Italie je pense que
c'était dans la ville de Saint-Vincent
il avait peut-être 8 9 ans
et j'étais avec un pote et je lui ai dit
tu vois le gamin là-bas
il fait le malin mais il sera jamais
champion du monde
j'ai balancé cette phrase pleine de
lucidité qui semblait très lucide au
moment où je l'ai dit mais ouais mais
elle fait mal mais ça c'est la première
fois que j'ai vu Magnus j'ai sorti ça
visionnaire ouais j'ai eu du pif ouais
j'ai énormément de PIF sur celle là
ouais j'ai eu du Attal qu'avant là-bas
il sera jamais champion du monde lui
histoire vraie histoire vraie tournant
en Italie à Saint-Vincent je dis ça de
mes potes qui se reconnaîtra peut-être
qui s'appelle Tonio
et j'ai envoyé cette punch
mais donc ça la première fois que j'ai
entendu parler de Magnus la première
fois que je l'ai vu il était déjà très
impressionnant il avait déjà plein de
monde autour de ces parties alors qu'il
était tout petit mais c'est déjà un
phénomène c'est pour ça que j'ai envoyé
la punch en fait
là on a une
carence balade qui avance Tonio de
Montpellier ouais exactement
c'était en 2000 125 Vincent ce serait
possible de retrouver si vous retrouvez
sur la grille américaine du tournoi vous
allez me voir
vous avez pas fait un si mauvais tournoi
mais j'avais perdu contre un 2005 ans ou
un 2100 alors en trois j'avais donné une
qualité en un coup n'importe quoi après
il avait sué pendant 6h pour gagner il
avait fini par gagner j'étais écœuré
avec moins de vélo
quoi mais il était déjà fort
complexe à la position
que c'était trop dangereux pour son
royaume des dames des cartes d'amashcard
qui pouvait arriver vite
et pour l'instant qui est
moi j'avais dit ça complètement hasard
j'avais dit ça pour la peine j'en avais
rien à faire
si c'est ça en 2003 open
je fais 5 sur 9
j'avais fait une parfois combien
j'avais fait une parfaite à combien
est-ce que j'avais le sable dans ce
tournoi j'avais fini malade en plus
et moi j'ai fait combien tu as personne
regarde mon résultat c'est trop
vous avez dit ça ouais j'y vais trop
pour les caméras déjà
c'est de choper l'info dans le dans le
chat
fais attention il y a des G4 là qui
commence à se combiner pour enfermer le
fou
quatre émissions 9
c'est pour ça alors j'avais le seum
ah c'est trop
donc supprimer la dame pour empêcher G4
normal mais sur G4 il a le temps de
prendre et prendre
déjà joué un joueur du Top 20 actuel en
longueur par exemple
par exemple mais avant enfin je veux
plusieurs joueurs qui sont rentrés dans
le top 20
c'était 21 73 OK
et j'avais fait parfois combien et je
lui ai dit il y a une partie qui m'avait
vraiment plombé rond 2 ou 3
malheureusement
partie bête parti vraiment bête
tu as vraiment la tuile quoi la gaffe
alors que je jouais bien et tous les
autres rondes
c'était bien dans mon tournoi et j'ai
fait la gaffe vraiment bête ça arrive à
tout le monde après je m'étais quand
même ressaisis
je m'étais quand même ressaisis après
bon peu importe on est là pour regarder
ce match là mais comme vous me demandez
vous me parlez de Carsen ça m'a rappelé
le tournoi
en dessous on est là mais cette partie
m'avait plombée je me rappelle alors que
j'avais pas mal joué le reste du temps
ça force un peu G5 pour fouger 6
est-ce que ça manque de jouer de toi sur
plateau non ça me manque tellement pas
dans des trucs qui me manque le moins en
fait
trop long pour moi les tournois
j'aurais pas le j'aurais pas le goût de
prendre 10 jours pour pour faire un tour
d'échecs
ça me manque absolument pas
même de Blitz non ça me manque pas
ça me manque vraiment pas
c'est pas un gage de rejoindre si si
mais je l'ai fait
ah c'est 4 c'était bizarre comme coup
parce que ça bloque le fou
ouais si si je l'ai fait
il va faire H5 sur mon il va être bloqué
sur casse blanche et fou B5 va se
retrouver un peu hors-jeu c'est hyper
bien joué de la part de Magnus
mais bon il y a pas que ça il y a prise
aussi le pion B2 qui peut être en l'air
position et complexe
ça a l'air fort parce qu'il va mettre le
rang E7 et le Fou est complètement cut
en fait c'est terrible il s'est 4 le fou
ouais
si Magnus reprend 4 points là-dessus va
voir le seum quand même
il va faire tout au deux je pense il
fait tourber 3 qui est D1 roi F1
cavalise C3 il va y avoir
tout
seul coup je suppose
tellement bien joué de la part de Magnus
c'est surtout en G4 il y avait D3 tu
reprends le 4 D2 et D1 dames imparable
j'avais rien fait pour la partie arrêt
du sabot alors c'est filmé c'est
c'est B Cup frère il y a les replay sur
la chaîne
le tournoi IRL oui ça rentre
ça passe
5 très franchement j'ai pas la rêve de
cette ligne
mais ça paraît très logique
il va bouger le cavalier ça va lui
permettre de faire le 7
ouais c'est fou la partie qui vient de
gagner là il est tellement plus fort et
là ouais c'est qui suit parce qu'il va
jouer à une énième position relou
avec une avec un tel avantage ce n'est
vraiment pas dans son assiette je suis
d'accord avec toi si elle bleu mais pour
moi il est sur la lignée du match qu'il
a fait contre Ali raisin où il devait
vraiment pas gagner il est pas en forme
sur ce speech j'étais pas en forme en
Coupe du monde donc moi je suis pas
étonné que ce soit un match réellement à
sens unique
si Magnus gagne celle-là plus 5 Magnus
est plus fort en belette
déjà là le match pour moi il est plié
mais bon enfin ce sera
on va arriver à Adel de pliage
incroyable
déjà trop Magnus est battu western Line
qui a ça aurait été chance dans un LCC
ouais je prendrai 28 à 1 peut-être si
j'ai un peu de chance je mettrais un
point à un moment donné
on s'adapique sur Google en attendant le
match je vous le dis tout de suite
parce qu'il regarde le temps qui reste
j'ai fait une très bonne partie
d'ailleurs
je rajoute ferait mal sur ce format non
pourquoi
ça me prend vraiment pour un Belin dans
le chat c'est terrible
ça me prend vraiment pour un Belin comme
d'hab en fait
en gros tu sais les mecs me prennent
pour un Belin international alors que je
rappelle quand même pour le pour la
personne qui me manque de respect de
manière hallucinante
que j'ai quand même battu Wesley en 3
plus et en tournant à part en amical
tu as pensé à ouvrir un club d'échecs
King écoute j'ai pas j'ai pas les locaux
pour le faire c'est compliqué
tu pensais pas mal mais bon tu m'as
quand même manqué de respect de ouf
frère
la nuit contre Manu c'est 3 plus sains
aussi
c'est bien joué là de la part de Magnus
la prise d'espace dans une structure de
pions symétrique
un club en ligne ah non je vois pas je
vois pas trop l'intérêt
faudra peut-être un jour mais
actuellement je pense que ça offre pas
de pourrai pas offrir de plus-value donc
on a déjà pensé à le faire mais
bon après c'est bien pour se faire de la
thune attention mais
là comme ça c'était pas l'objectif de
base mais peut-être on le fera un jour
de façon à un moment donné
il faut aussi penser Kaya mais en soi
on a déjà pensé avec Fab mais comme vous
pouvez pas offrir de plus-value par
rapport aux outils qui se font déjà en
ligne et qui sont très qualitatifs
on a préféré pas le faire
et faire d'autres médias
genre des livres ou peut-être la déco
sur Châble pour par la suite qui nous
semble plus intéressant
si tu peux le faire hier elle oui mais
si tu le fais en ligne
après je dis pas qu'on le fera jamais
parce que financièrement c'est très
intéressant
donc il va se placer l'avantage d'espace
position elle doit être nulle sur un jeu
parfait vous voyez la jauge mais il va
encore une fois tourner avec le Caraïbes
il va le mettre en F4 il va jouer sur
l'avantage d'espace il va être très
pénible
non mais des fois où j'en ai parlé avec
format on a parlé quelquefois avec on se
dit que si on le faisait il faudrait
qu'il y ait des événements
IRL qui est lieu etc donc
compliqué dis-moi on aime bien faire des
trucs vraiment bien donc faudrait que le
contenu soit mieux que ce qu'on fait
déjà gratuitement sur Youtube que ce qui
est fait sur chaque COM qui est déjà
exceptionnel en terme de vidéo
donc c'est pas
pas facile
c'est pas facile d'offrir vraiment
quelque chose de qualitatif et qui offre
une plus-value on pense que plus faire
une plus-value avec des cours vraiment
bien fait surchaebal
sa bataille c'est chaud organisé bah on
va en faire une samedi frère donc
là c'est 0-0 parce que oui c'est la
dernière partie de la cadence Manu va
faire qualifier deux cavaliers F4 mais
normalement ça doit faire nul
c'est pas par 7 non malheureusement ça
mettrait plus de suspense
il y a un point marqué sur cette partie
exactement ou un demi point minus qui
fait tout pour trouver une manière de
gagner ou que vous étiez bon je sais pas
trop quoi vous dire ce que j'ai deux KF4
mais je vois bien que ça a pas suffire
on va voir comment Magnus décide de
faire après va jouer avec C4 sûrement je
sais pas comment il va réussir ça mais
il va réussir ça
et le match de mvl ce sera demain
à 18h
il commence par ces quatre ne demandez
pas les finesse là franchement c'est un
niveau qui me dépasse trop
on va demander à Magnus le secret de
l'ordre de coup là peut-être qu'il veut
tout reprendre
je suis en train de me dire
est-ce qu'il a torture
F5 à la fin je pense
merci pour les particuliers gratuites
que tu partages qui pour moi coûte une
fortune bah elles sont gratuites frère
pas forcément la relève
ok tourage de ouais il maintient des
tours des cavaliers 6 ouais c'est hyper
pénible à jouer on voit ouais qui fait
non de la tête mais là ce que fait
Magnus il y a que Magnus qui sait le
faire en fait
courage 7 c'est bien joué ça enlève les
cavaliers si c'est sec
je trouvais pas la défense
waouh c'est très bien défendu parce que
on prend H4 intermédiaire et puis on
prend un écran G6
c'est très bien défendu
et sur kij6 direct qui est franchise
fou des trois mais
cavalier aussi pour continuer à jouer
pas assez fort ce qu'ils font
ce que tu rages je crois il y a roi G2
il tient les cases
non mais Magnus c'est hallucinant le
niveau de jeu là dans le petit jeu de
placement
alors là il va échanger en dessin qui va
jouer de tourage de ouais bien joué
il va essayer de le revisser avec le
cavalier qui vient E3 ouais tout
recettes c'est bien joué
il va mettre le Cavaillon H5
mais ça va faire nul il y a pas de case
d'entrée
il peut complètement fermé la Wesley
il y a pas de risque en fait
cavalier 3 tiens tout
et la position est complètement fermée
pour les deux
Magnus qui tente quand même le maximum
c'est fou
là il peut rien y faire
ok ça va tourner à 6 2 mais énorme
avantage fond Magnus Carlson on verra si
peu maintenir ce rythme dans le 3 plus 1
mais très franchement vu comment c'est
parti je vois pas comment ouais c'est
pour retourner ce match on est bien
curieux de le voir à tout de suite les
amis
vous les streamer des échecs comme vos
créateurs préférés tels que Bill stream
Naka ou les soeurs
le programme de Community streamer de
Chess.com est fait pour vous débutant
dans le streaming ou déjà expérimenté
peu importe c'est le moyen idéal pour
élargir votre audience vous connectant
votre compte à cheese.com et profiter de
la visibilité offerte alors notre
plateforme de jeu il vous suffit de
relier votre compte à
cheese.com/ettings/connecting tiret
ecuns mettre échec comme catégorie sur
twitch et commencer à streamer
d'une expérience sans publicité sur
chaise.com et apparaître et dans notre
liste de streamer en direct votre
profits.com affichera votre stream
twitch qui sera aussi mis en avant
durant vos parties au fort utiliser la
commande community streamer dans le chat
et faites grossir votre audience sans
plus attendre
[Musique]
je suis un petit peu inquiet parce que
même les Américains réussissent plus
trop à il pleut match donc je suis assez
inquiet
qui enlève son pull
on va attaquer le 3 + 1 mais ouais ça
semble être un match à sens unique
même les Américains
suis un petit peu pour
ça va reprendre là mais pour ouais pour
vibrer quoi
tu vas payer quoi plus qu'à généralement
il t'invente des délires en mode ouais
mais il peut remonter nanani nanana mais
là le
le souci qu'ils ont pour hype c'est que
c'est que donc il y a eu quatre mais
c'est qu'en fait Magnus est censé être
beaucoup plus fort en belette donc
même si ça a gagné plus de ou plus 3 le
3 + 1 ma illus resterait écrasant
favoris
donc en soi c'est enfin c'est le
problème du match là c'est qu'en fait
c'est des équilibré en trois plus un en
faveur
c'est juste 5 + 5 on a fini ouais
ouais là ça semble
ça semble relativement difficile
de revenir
plus simple on entend récupérer par coup
exactement plus simple c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'incrément
donc le temps ouais que tu que tu
récupères exactement
c'est exactement ça
tu le verras demain dans la vidéo de
demain matin tu verras Fab et
normalement il commente avec moi demain
mais en fait il y a eu un nouveau
changement d'horaire donc je vais devoir
lui demander
je vais devoir lui demander si peu parce
que c'est vrai que les horaires ont
beaucoup beaucoup changé
on va voir ce que donne la petite
italienne j'ai l'impression que le match
est vraiment dans un faux rythme
maintenant
et vendredi donc le watch la Watch Party
à Paris
venez nombreux en libre normalement ce
sera à 19h mais je vous confirmerai
l'horaire une fois qu'il sera qui sera
officiel
on suivra ça ensemble depuis les spot à
Paris ce sera sympa
surtout si à Maxime qui joue
allez on voit Magnus qui a réussi à
jouer plus vite et qui sort
tranquillement de l'ouverture une
nouvelle fois
tout à l'heure normalement vers les vers
19h
ok bah si on jouait des cinq maintenant
il va sûrement jouer pour des 5 c'est
vous pour Manu c'est au-dessus de tout
le monde est champion comme Fisher ou
Castorama autant la concurrence
ça me paraît assez unique après
ouais c'est combien il a perdu quelques
places au classement mais il était top
10 Mondy top top 5 10 mondial top 5 même
mondial il y a il y a pas si longtemps
là il a perdu pas mal de vélo
de temps aux alentours de la 10e place
là actuellement elle va voir qui va lui
prendre des seins qui se fait marcher
dessus en fait
ouais ce sera très libre vendredi
j'espère qu'on aura un beau match
normalement on aura le Fab de toute
façon donc fabule est toujours là pour
gueuler
vu que Magnus gagne ce soir dans tous
les cas ce serait une belle finale si
c'est Magnus contre contre Maxime on va
on va kiffer de folie mais ici c'est
Magnus contre Carouge je pense que ce
sera un beau match aussi besoin du
tambourrer bref je pense le tambour tu
peux tu peux le prendre tu laisses pas
hein tout le temps besoin d'un tambour
frérot
les gens sont pas content à quel point
qu'elle soit fait atomiser des chèques
dans des moments des échecs pendant 20
ans ouais après Magnus il fait aussi un
sacré boulot
en termes de démolisseur il est pas
mauvais non plus
et puis si le match est pourri on
regardera pas jusqu'au bout on pourra
égo faire une partie en bas de LoL tous
ensemble peut-être
si le match qui est à 20h30 il y a 6
points d'écart on va pas ça va pas caste
jusqu'au bout je vous annonce on regarde
le truc jusqu'à 21h et c'est ciao ouais
ça abandon pour Wesley je pense que ça
là c'était le dernier le dernier coup
dans dans le cercueil de Wesley dame F6
qu'il a complètement atomisé ça fait 7
et demi deux et demi franchement
c'est un hommage
pour moi ce match c'est ce qu'on appelle
une déchirure
bah il joue la il joue la nage d'Arve
ton géant répertoire bien sûr
à chaque fois j'ai 5 quoi c'est même pas
forcément la meilleure variante ce que
je vous saut il se fait vite
et la tension ça peut ça peut être cher
à la sortie
c'est possible on n'a pas le droit
d'abandonner les matchs
on sera obligé de jouer jusqu'au bout
côté Wesley et c'est une nouvelle purgea
ça pour le public malheureusement pas
comme je disais on n'a pas de réussite
cette année sur les matchs de speechers
alors il y a eu Ali resa contre St mais
qui est un match très décousu et
honnêtement si les observateurs tels que
moi étaient pas si par le match c'est
que le niveau de jeu était pas ouf et on
le voit aujourd'hui en fait c'était pas
ouais ouais les l'écart avec les
meilleurs étaient quand même visible
t'inquiète ça fait plaisir de te voir
là-bas
attention quand même
pas la peine non plus dans le chat de
s'auto qu'on gratulé parce que vous
allez vous voir cinq minutes c'est quand
même gênant côté blurri fait call flow
c'est pas réservé l'hôtel bon voilà ça
commence un peu à être inquiétant pas
trop de quoi il parle tous
un petit peu peur alors j'ai trois F4
c'est tellement bien joué
ouais là on va avoir un match en roue
libre en fait c'est
pas avoir de belles passes d'armes à
certainement je suis à faire F4
et sur pion prend foi H4 et à faire roi
des deux pour roi C1
et faire un rock à la main je pense
on va essayer plus c'est mort ouais
ouais je suis d'accord avec toi police
fan of toda mais
minus sont plus j'ai l'impression que
plus personne n'y est là le match a trop
trop pris d'ampleur
je suis pas sûr qu'elle
en fait c'est juste qu'il était un peu
je sais pas ce qui lui arrivait sur la
portion de de 5 + 1 contre contre WC
était pas motivé ou je sais pas
c'est marrant on ne connaît pas vraiment
la vie des joueurs d'échec à côté de la
compète genre on ne sait pas si mainus
ou Maxime ont une copine alors on sait
c'est toi qui sait pas Guilhem
mais c'est pas non plus la vie des
joueurs d'échec c'est pas gala genre tu
sais pas
j'aurais pas que les joueurs d'échec en
fait
mais oui enfin nous on a toujours su
c'est juste que tu es mal renseigné mais
moi je sais mais je te dirai pas mais je
sais enfin j'ai toujours su en plus
il faut plus de vlades sur les streams
en fait là il lâche les infos
pourquoi tu veux savoir
à moi c'est juste mes potes donc enfin
c'est mes potes la maxime c'est mon pote
et puis du coup j'ai quelques bails quoi
donc à la main
mais sinon je m'en tape totalement
globalement
il va se rendre F4 dans l'attente il va
se faire défoncer
ouais c'est là c'est terrible pour pour
c'est difficile
ouais qui arrive il y a tout qui s'ouvre
le roi qui va se retrouver aux abois
souvent des métiers quand c'est en ligne
bah il y a trop de tournoi en fait
et même s'il y a beaucoup d'argent
c'est pas facile
d'avoir un rendement toujours à 100% on
l'a après je pense que Wesley c'est
surtout le match qui se passe mal
et bonne soirée pour la vraie
demi-finale de demain
et la partie du prêt ah ouais demain 18h
demain 18h on a qu'à n'a qu'à ça va
valoir le coup d'oeil enfin je dis ça
ça dépend du scénario si c'est un
scénario de match comme aujourd'hui
ce sera kata mais si c'est un match
serré ça va être très très cool
bon allez est-ce que peut voler celle-là
pour garder de l'intérêt ce serait pas
le cas enfin ouais non bon il y a de
toute façon trop d'écart mais
revenir à 4 points avoir un micro
frisson quoi
un Brisson
impression est dur un nouveau cas avec
6 fois 5
il y a un monde n'a qu'à plus 6 après
les 5 plus 5 moi il me fait toujours
peur en a qu'à pas se mentir
j'ai peur de NACA quoi je suis
[Musique]
j'ai peur quoi
il va faire rabais 4 non
les rois B4 c'est trop
c'est trop
c'est trop le pion des trop avancé et ça
fait Punto j'ai essayé trop parce que ça
se voyait qu'il allait faire bouffer
qu'il allait se faire bouffer D6 c'est
que et que ça allait pousser
les calculs ne sont pas bon et ça fait
plus 6
ouais donc là on est sur une humiliante
l'intérêt du match est complètement
parti
quel joueur qui fait le plus peur à
jouer maintenant
tu sais
je suis quelqu'un de compétitif j'ai
envie de te dire moi-même
je me fais peur frère
ça a terminé à combien bah je sais pas
m'amuse va perdre de l'intérêt à un
moment donné ça va pas trop enfler je
pense
mais ouais c'est terrible pour le speed
chasse cette année
ouais c'est un très très beau format je
sens que c'est bien de ta raison de le
de le préciser c'est un magnifique
forfait c'est un peu la Rolls-Royce des
échecs en ligne c'est tu vois vraiment
qui est le meilleur là ça menace C6 D5
c'est vraiment cataclysmique et sur ces
6 x 4 il y a B5
malheureusement il faut des matchs
serrés pour que ce soit intéressant et
là on a juste pas de chance
surtout que là en plus de ça Carlson est
nettement plus fort en belette enfin
nettement et un peu plus fort en belette
donc il y a même pas ce petit frisson de
te dire ouais sur le bolet et ce qui
peut revenir
ce sera un nom
mais je crois que les
je crois que les audiences sont à
même en anglais je crois que les gens
accrochent plus trop c'est
c'est enfin en tout cas sur ce match je
crois que les gens se barrent même si
c'est un américain contre Carlsen
il y a pas grand monde en fait
les gens ont un peu le SAM quoi
mais je peux comprendre
c'est juste que à partir d'un moment
donné
malheureusement il faut appeler un chat
quoi le match est terminé
un chat
coupé 5 même encore plus fort peut-être
même parfois il se rapporte ouais c'est
même pas en vrai c'est même pas 5 parce
que
c'est plus 7 8000 que 14000 en fait donc
ouais
mais bon ouais mais c'est très très peu
sur cette compétition
les gens accrochent pas trop mais comme
je sais c'est on n'a pas vraiment eu de
beaux matchs
et puis on a quand même beaucoup de
compétitions il y a encore une autre
compétition qui recommence la semaine
prochaine ça n'arrête pas en fait
quand il se passe rien ouais c'est ça le
format est cool mais quand il se passe
rien c'est bon
et moi je vais venir quand il y aura une
belle nacre ouais ouais j'espère enfin
moi j'espère pas un beau match demain
j'espère que Maxime Le défonce en fait
j'en ai rien à faire
moi je veux rien savoir je veux juste
Victor de mvl et ça me ça me suffit
amplement
je sais plus quoi
est-ce que j'étais en train de calculer
désolé je commentais pas je suis en
train de calculer prise F5 ou F5 direct
à la cavalière de cavalier
ça a l'air de fermer fort
et peut-être miraculeusement tenir
d'après NACA demain c'est 80 20
enfin en sa faveur
ça me paraît assez juste
par Magnus qui va jouer pour eux deux
tu vas faire en C4 là je pense
ouais c'est trop trop bien joué il a
bloqué le cavalier il a fait un super
enchaînement la bague nue il a bloqué le
cavalier avec l'IDE hein
donc ouais même quand il baisse un peu
le rythme il rate pas les win
system de Londres maintenant
mais bon l'écart les quarts est
tellement sévère c'est plus 7 c'est ça
ouais plus 7 c'est
ça existe cette variante
F6 dommage 5 on en parle plus
ouais le score
extrêmement sévère mais qui reflète la
différence de niveau entre les deux
hommes ce soir
voilà il est plus il est plus dans son
assiette
il a plus envie de jouer
ouais quand tu sais que tu dois rester
encore pendant deux heures à 6 là c'est
dur
même en nous ça nous assure d'avoir un
watch party sympa vendredi soir comme je
disais soit sénaca n'a qu'à Carlsen
c'est les deux meilleurs joueurs du
monde dans le format qui s'affronte donc
ça va être sympa
et on sait pour qui on sera c'est assez
facile
soit ce sera
Carlsen mvl
et bon là il y a même pas il y a même
pas de mots à prononcer la hype est réel
donc oui c'est simple dans tous les cas
on sera pour Magnus si c'est NACA bien
évidemment sans aucune hésitation
il se fait déchirer je pense il se fait
juste ouvrir
ses ouvertures ouais c'est
c'est une torture ce match
Manu qui est très tranquille qui le
défonce ou assez qui qui a plus les
coups le pauvre
ouais là c'est c'est un supplice qu'on
est en train c'est une torture qu'on est
en train d'infliger à wesleo
là la seule chance à mon avis pour
rester pour un peu revenir dans le match
c'est d'écouter du naps
dans le carré à S 5 Wi-Fi en espèces à
mon avis il y a que ça qui peut le
ouais de la kiffance
du Yann
là mais à mon avis il faut vraiment
mettre du naps là naps
ok
ça se termine en fait
ça termine la game en fait kicb 5 à 6
Damas 5
je leur dis que ça termine pas si on
prend en cavalier prend
B6 Damas ah parce qu'il y a le fou F4 en
l'air désolé
bon cavalier assez
prendre des 8 et 6
c'est ciao ouais bon c'est une
déchirante il fait n'importe quoi ouais
c'est il y a même plus de parties là là
il y a pas de partie en fait il fait
n'importe quoi
il se fait déchirer bon j'ai même pas
employé les termes pour éviter toute
vulgarité mais quand il se fait des
séries de déchirer vous savez à quoi je
pense quoi
c'est ça fait plaisir à personne un
match comme ça
c'est pas c'est
dur c'est dur c'est dur
je sais pas ce qu'il doit faire là
mais clairement il y a plus de match
c'est parti
il reste combien de temps de carnage il
va y rester encore une heure de jeu et
avec les pauses encore une heure et
demie
on a encore ensemble pendant une heure
et demie c'est bon
désolé c'est des matchs qui sont très
très compliqués à commenter parce que
je me répète mais
il est parti on sent que les joueurs ont
du mal à se motiver on a du mal à se
motiver à les regarder aussi très
honnêtement
pardon la nuit comme ça
ouais c'est comme un match de foot où il
y a 5 ou 6 buts d'écart quoi à la
mi-temps
ouais en plus
on est plus dans la qualité des parties
ça clique quoi
qu'est-ce que c'est dur pour la repère
ça là encore et je pense qu'il est
reparti pour un
enfin qu'il est parti pour la repeindre
c'est terrible
un petit avantage de
d'activité
un peu plus serré un peu plus longtemps
et puis ça avait mal tourné
puis après il y avait le Bullet là c'est
vraiment
là c'est triste
j'ai trois il va faire roi 7
il a raté fou prends bien ton problème
de fout des trois peu importe quoi
ça c'est une gaffe en un coup d'ouest
il a oublié qu'il y avait pas tout ce
qui n'a pas tout rêve de parce qu'il y a
tout droit ouais c'est encore ça perd
sur une gaffe en fait
il avait qu'à jouer avec ses trois et il
y avait rien
et c'était juste nul en fait
mais ouais non non il est
enfin là juste il fait des gaffes de
débutant quoi il fait des gaffes de mon
niveau en fait il fait des gaffes qu'on
fait à mon niveau
c'est pour ça que c'est dur de commenter
parce qu'en fait ça finit sur des gaffes
de joueurs qui sont 29 29 29 57 comme
mais normalement à ce niveau là on
envoie plus du tout et là toutes les
Games c'est ça
c'est les gars que tu vois ouais encore
entre 27,50 et 29 50 sur chess com au
dessus tu les vois plus normalement
c'est trop facile
mais oui bon là ça s'explique le match
est
terminé plus 9 même si gagner 5 parties
en 3 + 1 la dafiler le Bullet il en
remontera pas 4 bon sur ce petit pause
et on se retrouve
dans un jour complètement sans ouais
saviez-vous que vous pouvez pimenter vos
parties en ligne et vous analyses avec
des emojis il vous suffit de cliquer sur
l'icône emoji puis de sélectionner votre
emoji et de cliquer avec le bouton
gauche de la souris sur l'échiquier vous
pouvez choisir parmi une multitude de
notation de coûts
et même vos personnalités préférées du
monde des échecs ils émoticônes et les
emojis disparaîtront au bout de quelques
secondes en revanche notations de coûts
et les animations spéciales restent sur
l'échiquier jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit
effacées pour ce faire il suffit de
cliquer avec le bouton gauche de la
souris sur l'emoji ou de cliquer sur le
bouton Tout effacer
[Musique]
essayez tous et amusez-vous bien sur
Chess.com
[Musique]
yo yo yo yo yo on est de retour petit
truc intéressant
j'ai regardé
un peu le live en anglais il y avait un
débat dans le chat et les gens pensent
que le match devrait être arrêté j'ai un
peu de chèque on n'est pas les seuls
avancer que le match devrait devrait
continuer le public anglais a aussi fait
un vote et a débattu dans le chat et
penser ouais qu'à un moment donné bon
c'est trop c'est trop quoi
ça devient juste pénible pour tout le
monde en fait
ouais c'est pas agréable de voir un
genre
se faire se faire défoncer comme ça plus
personne prendre de plaisir
c'est un peu dommage
moi je pense qu'à plus 7 tout de suite
les matchs devraient s'arrêter quoi
et puis ça plombe le moral de tout le
monde hein très franchement
voilà nous on a perdu beaucoup
d'audience et c'est tant mieux en
quelque sorte que c'est
genre raison d'aller dormir faut garder
son énergie pour pour le match de demain
je crois pas et puis bon au bout d'un
moment je sais pas c'est comme un chaos
quoi fallait pas être avant 8
donc là ils peuvent pas arrêter le match
mais c'est tout comme un
donc il y avait plus 5 + 6 tu dis à
moyen une petite remontada mais 9 points
c'est
en fait je crois que c'est comme
pourquoi ils aiment faire les matchs
jusqu'au bout
je crois déjà pour les sponsors c'est
plus facile mais
je pense qu'au-delà de ça ils espèrent
vraiment toujours ils sont hyper
positifs en fait les gens chez comme
généralement ils se perdent toujours
avoir des matchs hyper serrés et des
come-back et des trucs comme ça donc je
pense un peu dans l'espoir d'avoir des
comags de folie mais bon ça arrive
jamais quoi quasiment
ouais c'est l'intérêt des formations
[Musique]
en fait
ils ont dû aimer exactement en fait ils
espèrent des matchs comme ça
mais bon firuso c'était mon cas plus 5
un pas plus
d'un assistant bien
désolé un dur aussi pour votre
commentateur de garder l'intérêt dans le
match comme pour les joueurs
parce que
j'ai dit en soit pas fait un super match
contre un très très beau match
donc non je pense que
ça aurait été la même
peut-être pas aussi sévère après
dans la colonne B
je suis un peu moi aussi là
il sert les dents quand même
il va peut-être la tenir
comme ça un peu dans cette partie oui
bien joué
il va y avoir droit
il va ramener le rang B3 je pense
ça c'est terrible
parce que pour rien
c'est terrible il va plat game pour rien
dame C8 et
il a juste dit up la game pour rien
ouais c'est
et si ça suffisait pas ça fait encore un
point de plus
ouais non il s'accroche pas il peut pas
il peut plus jouer il a plus le il s'est
tellement dur je vais contre Magnus
dès que tu as fui la motivation que tu
prends cher et tout tu peux plus
il y a rien quoi
il a la motive voilà il a plus vraiment
il fait quand même des gaffes
qui pour son niveau son
pas normal mais
ouais c'est comme ça il a la taille il a
ce qu'on appelle avoir la tête sous
l'eau
c'est vraiment ce qu'on appelle avoir la
tête sous l'eau
plus facile quand même de rester
concentré pour ma news comme il domine
le match
ouais
je pense qu'on l'a déjà vu ça
ça doit être égal en plus ou moins ce
truc là
le moment
j'arrive plus à calculer
juste OK
en fait le cavalier il tient les cases
noires quoi
à la demande pour Adrien
il arrive plus à jouer
c'est l'enfer sur terre pour lui
c'est parti
c'est l'enfer sur terre pour lui c'est
parti
jusqu'à ce qu'on va essayer d'en avoir
les données les game
c'est Magnus qui provoque
des 8 tours des deux et
et rentrer
des 8 et il va tenter tourner deux
après dans la dans sa gestion de match
nul c'est très bien
tu gardes
c'était sûr qu'il ferait ça
moi j'étais sûr qu'il rentrerait
là-dedans
parce que le roi va réussir à arriver en
E5
il a oublié la pièce en un
alors c'est pas terminé mais c'est
terrible
il a oublié
il a oublié cette ligne
il a encore oublié quelque chose
j'avais pas vu non plus et j'ai plus
réagi à la jauge honnêtement
mais bon c'est dur de s'en aller quand
un match est terminé est terminé
il est dégoûté il arrive plus à jouer ça
dégoûte de regarder ça en fait
moi aussi ça me dégoûte personnellement
au bout d'un moment c'est trop enfin ça
me dégoûte dans le sens dans le sens
empathique du terme
juste à un moment donné tu as plus envie
de voir ça quoi
il a raté ma tendin c'est possible ça
allait vite
j'ai l'impression qu'il y avait tout le
temps échec pour les Noirs mais bon
ma nuit c'est très régulier et puis là
il a l'empreinte sur le match puis wesh
la plus envie de jouer et puis il y a
rien qui va
pourquoi Manu se colle pas avec des
bancs parce que il est respectueux c'est
plutôt positif là qui le fasse pas
même son adversaire au fond du trou il
le respecte
mais c'est plutôt louable de la part de
Magnus
forcément
sauce est trop ce qu'il fait
ouais c'est encore une finale pas simple
c'est long
pour
5 à 4
ça dégoûte
tu crois que
dans le match
ouais pour moi il était comme je disais
il est passé un peu entre les gouttes
les tours d'avant il est pas en forme en
ce moment et c'est tout
fait un gros match après
il y a rien à lui enlever mais
ah il veut juger 5 et fous prends ces
trois qui est ça marche pas
ce qui a tombé trois à la fin gave de
Minus
c'est la même moi je l'avais
mais il est obligé de faire roisser 6
quand même
il a oublié de tomber trop en fin de
variante
il faut qu'il aille celle-là Wesley
genre vraiment
c'est ce que je pensais surtout aux deux
il veut roi des trois
il va prendre perpète
ok il évite l'adoption
mais bon ça rapproche encore un peu plus
Magnus de la victoire dans le match
donc il y aura pas d'adoption il y a
vraiment plus aucun enjeu de rien
car oui 40 secondes
il est tout sourire ouais mais il est
dépité
c'est du dépit
c'est juste du dépit les amis
on se fait crush comme ça
ouais tu te sens pas forcément très bien
c'est pas très agréable
non non ça va lui faire de la caillasse
quand même mais
on craquage ouais ouais ouais il est en
craquage
il est un peu il est un peu comme nous
quoi il est un peu
je sais pas j'ai même pas le thème
ouais ouais parce que le score va être
plus sombre de toute façon
pressée
est-ce que le
de match comme ça ça va pousser jusqu'à
adopter un jour le format 7
je fais la propagande depuis longtemps
j'espère
que c'est
car de 55
c'est un peu le côté nouveauté aussi un
prêt c'est comme tout hein faut évoluer
là mais on n'a pas de chance avec les
matchs
là très franchement on a pas de bol
je me répète mais cette année
c'est vraiment tout mal tombé
ce qui se passe sur des trois tours à
deux mais là je me disais tu reprends à
deux c'est fini
de m'inventer pas des talons que je n'ai
pas
je suis un très décembre mais pas au
point de de mieux jouer que ces
positions
ça c'est pas le cas
il est fort en belette il est très fort
en belette
encore une fois
ce qu'on va réussir à arriver au bout du
chrono
pour avoir une partie de moi
un supplice de moins pour Wesley
on va arriver à avoir un supplice de
moins il reste plus que 10 secondes en
trois plus un
allez c'est peut-être déjà ça
il va peut-être la tenir en plus c'est
normal voilà
il a réussi un tout petit peu stopper
l'hémorragie
ou pas
ça n'avait pas vu il se fait bloquer la
tour
est-ce que je me demandais ça c'est pour
moi ça avait l'air nul
il va faire H5 mais ça doit faire nul au
tempo
allez
ça va mieux nul ça permet de tourner à 3
et demi
petite pause mesdames et messieurs on
revient pour la fin du match et le Bolet
à tout de suite
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surpris à du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechestre
les titles Tuesday
chase.com/aventem poulet plus grands
tournois d'échec qui se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez comprenez
en direct les parties des meilleurs
joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentiels
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition aux pronostiquant les
résultats ont tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chaise.com sash
events aussi bien sur le site internet
que sur nos applications iOS et Android
pour vivre votre passion comme nulle
part ailleurs
[Musique]
on est de retour les amis
j'ai raté j'ai raté le début
c'est pas très grave
j'ai raté une game j'ai plus de plus de
tu fais dépasser par une pause express
qui sait qui a gagné la première
j'ai raté et celui qui fait les scores
aussi
bon
même pour la régie par résume tout le
monde a quitte le match
ma mère il va lui placer un
fou H3 dame D7 s'ils peuvent aussi dans
des sept fois je crois peut-être
bien joué ouais quand même là
match et après il sera il sera libéré
US qui a pas réussi à mater
ouais
ça va faire nul mais dur de s'emballer
c'est combien de points d'écart au final
se fait 12 points quand même
ça va ça tient
ça se joue au tempo
mais là le pion ça y est il avance
c'est trop
c'est trop ça en fait encore une
les carrés
hallucinant
trois points et demi ouais
c'est complètement fou quand on y pense
c'est tellement peu ouais je sais que
je crois qu'il y a une victoire
seulement ouais
le match infini
ne ratez pas j'espère que ce sera plus
beau match que celui-là
ce sera pas une purge à ça
quand même ouais c'est qui va la gagner
ça va quand même
ah non c'est minus c'est plus fort que
Wesley SOS ça c'est sûr
intrinsèquement et pas dans un monde
bonjour donc le mélange déjà fait mal
ouais c'est dur pour les spectateurs
après personne vous oblige à regarder
non plus hein
si vous voulez regarder vous regardez si
vous voulez pas regarder vous regardez
pas donc
que Wesley qui suit
fait partie du sport aussi ouais après
le format mais dans des conditions ou
des tas de trucs peuvent arriver quoi
voilà
il y avait mais
il a raté F4 et tour H1 il s'était fait
matant de tout seul ouais
mais là il sait même plus gagner qu'une
pièce de plus quand même
heureusement que Magnus a raté
c'était maté tout seul
genre 1er degré c'est plus jouer aux
échecs en fait
il devait gagner
c'était vraiment F4 tu auras un mat
c'est incroyable même une pièce nette de
plus dans une position facile il est pas
capable de la gagner ouais non il est
vraiment pas en forme là il est
complètement désabusé
durant très dur
très très très dur quand c'est comme ça
c'est très très très très très très dur
c'est la difficulté
jusqu'à la
bon je me répète mais j'ai l'impression
qu'elle irait faire un mauvais match
ils ont chaud m'avait pas paru fort
évidemment très fort mais je savais pas
paru un grand saut contre alias
on le sent un peu emprunté en ce moment
c'est dommage pour les fans et pour la
compétition de pas avoir de belles
demi-finale mais
ah il joue le truc Armageddon en même
temps en Allemagne
j'ai complètement oublié ce truc en plus
je savais j'ai pas fait le rapprochement
ah mais oui c'est pour ça alors
alors c'est pour ça oui oui bon c'est
normal alors
oui si je joue en un autre tournant en
même temps c'est sûr
ah oui oui non en fait
désolé j'avais plus la ref
mais oui ça explique alors
ça explique
ci-joint il joue un autre tournant en
même temps en fait ouais donc c'est
ouais c'est dur de jouer deux tournants
en même temps contre des joueurs de
skalibrer il a fait quoi contre surtout
que c'est des formats différents
il était déjà à Berlin pour le match
contre contre
ces obus la journée ouais mais c'est
jamais de Blitz la journée Floki
c'est c'est ça ça te prend de l'influx
ça te prend du machin
puis ça fait plusieurs jours qu'il est
sur l'autre tournoi aussi
j'allais machin les médias et tout
ça explique quelques petits trucs
ouais mais bon quand on parle de ce
calendrier des chèques où il y a trop de
tournois bah les mecs jouent carrément
deux tournois à la fois quoi maintenant
ça devient
ça devient hallucinant en fait
c'est trop
tellement de trucs qui se tellement de
tourner dans le calendrier que ça finit
par se chevaucher quoi
non mais c'est réellement en pénalisant
un de jouer plusieurs fois en même temps
les échecs nous étonnerons toujours
dans la position est nulle mais
peut-être que comme ils en ont marre de
jouer ils vont
[Musique]
temporiser le maximum
je pense Magnus va être sympa et
comprendre ce que wesh les fait
non même pas ils font nuls
ion en même temps dans le calendrier
elle vivait
donc autant prendre l'argent dans les
deux tournois en même temps c'est normal
en fait ce qui fait Wesley au moins il
prend l'argent au truc Armageddon et là
contre Magnus façon il était favori pour
perdre donc comme ça il prend l'argent
aussi de ce côté là je pense qu'il y a
un beau chèque aussi au tournoi des
dents
donc c'est très pragmatique et très
normal de faire ce qui fait
pour moi il y a pas de il y a pas de
souci il prend l'argent
ce qui s'en fout en fait
non mais contre Magnus il était favori
pour perdre donc s'il peut reprendre
encore 20 30 000 euros en jouant l'autre
tournant en même temps bah c'est sur 20
30 000 euros de plus quoi
c'est pourquoi d'autres que pour
l'argent rien en fait
il file une pièce en un ouais c'est
pas c'est pas normal on peut pas
reprocher à un joueur professionnel
de mettre ces finances
au premier plan
c'est normal il y a absolument rien
d'anormal dans cette attitude
bien au contraire
c'est juste que
il va pas cracher sur 20 30 000 euros
quoi
il est pas assez riche pour ça quoi
je sais pas s'il va abandonner le match
il reste 10 minutes il y a déjà 15
points d'écart
il va encore perdre
est-ce qu'il va abandonner le match ou
pas
même pas on va devoir rester encore 10
minutes devant
c'est un des moins beaux matchs de
speech que j'ai vu au final
Magnus très beau match a rien à dire
mais ouais c'est il était vraiment pas
au niveau ce soir
et c'était franchement pas un beau match
de speechestre il a commis énormément de
gaffe
pour une demi-finale après j'ai vu des
matchs pire évidemment
premier deuxième tour mais là pour une
demi-finale c'était vraiment pas c'était
vraiment pas fou
car on avait ce Magnus ouais mais
c'était un quart non
et pas une demi je crois
ml Carl sense c'était une très belle
demi-heure
mais là c'est dommage parce que ouais
ouais c'est là vraiment pas
tu as tellement habitué à mieux mais bon
c'est vrai que maintenant que vous me
rappelez qu'il faut un autre tournant en
même temps tout commence à
faire du sens
gagner à 4 Magnus à la finale avec mais
ouais
il va faire tout reprendre
une petite nul
ça fait 21 à 5
c'est bien mais après ouais demain 18h
Magnus tu as fait bien dominer l'an
dernier en finale contre
il était pas dans son assiette non plus
ouais
il jouait mal relativement à Magnus
il avait encore le droit de faire
non non
on prend encore une fois un jouet les
deux tours en même temps c'est quand
même assez osé aussi il va faire dame
prend 4 je pense ah non il peut pas
faire le cavalier à la fin
malheureusement
c'est tromper Magnus là
il s'est trompé
mal
allez la dernière ou la dernière et on
se quittera je vous souhaitera tous une
bonne nuit merci d'être resté en ma
compagnie aussi longtemps
désolé pour le
pour le spectacle mais
on est malheureusement tributaire des
joueurs
ah non j'y peux rien et puis je peux pas
mieux vous commenter ça que ce que j'ai
fait ce soir parce que
je sais pas quoi dire qu'on va pas
mettre de live pour quelle raison
demain je comprends très avec avec Fab
mais voilà c'est vraiment indépendant de
toute ma volonté match était plié en 45
minutes
genre vraiment plier
allez on va dire 45 minutes c'était 98 %
de chances pour minus 95 98 après 1h05
de match c'était 99,9 quoi
encore deux parties ouais il va rester
encore deux parties enfin encore une
partie après ça là
il va en rester encore une
pour le plaisir
quoique c'est un peu le suspense de la
partie c'est ce que
elle va durer plus de 50 secondes ça là
ou pas elle peut
c'est bon plus de Magnus que d'autres
choses
ça dépend combien de temps il tente en
fait
il va en rester une pour le plaisir
jusqu'au bout
jusqu'au bout de l'ennui ils vont nous
emmener les démons de minuit
vers la frontière
il a toujours été très jeune il a été
très fort ambulette
les 15 points d'écart pour le moment
de Bullet toi qu'il avait dit ça bon
après on s'en fout aussi un peu du
Bulletin
faudrait faire sur vrais
au moins
honnêtement les les interviews d'après
partis les commentaires sur le Bullet
c'est pas forcément
il va faire il y a pas qui est tombé ici
en fait
et ça va faire nul
ça va se terminer sur un 22 à 7 merci
les amis d'avoir suivi et comme je vous
le disais on se retrouve demain à 18h
pour la suite du speechasse avec la
magnifique demi-finale que posera mvl et
Karuna camera et vendredi soir on se
retrouvera normalement à 19h à Paris
entrée libre à Lisbonne pour suivre la
grande finale merci